mais à messieurs bonsoir ce dont nous
allons vous parler tout de suite
concerne plus de deux millions cinq cent
mille familles il s'agit du fameux
complément familial jusqu alors assez
controversé mais qui depuis hier est
examiné à l'assemblée nationale avec une
issue favorable il ya une demi-heure
aucun député n'a voté contre il a fallu
pour cela que le gouvernement fasse un
pas vers les députés de la majorité qui
étaient irrités par l'insuffisance des
crédits gouvernementaux
simone veil qui sera tout à l'heure
notre invité est intervenu pour les
rassurer en accordant une rallonge de
1,1 milliard de francs ce qui a mis tout
le monde d'accord
mais d'abord qu'est ce que le complément
familial eh bien il s'agit d'une somme
de 340 francs versés à bon nombre de
familles et qui va dès l'année prochaine
en place et les allocations de salaire
unique de mère au foyer et de frais de
garde
le complément familial se voulait sablé
ficap oeuvre en fait d'amendement en
amendement il est devenu presque aussi
complexe que l'ancien éventail des
allocations salir une i am au foyer
garderie qu'il va remplacer si l'on s'en
tient aux grandes lignes au départ un
principe est un chiffre vous toucherez
340 francs par famille et par mois mais
à certaines conditions
d'abord le nombre et l'âge des enfants
si vous avez au moins un enfant de moins
de 3 ans vous toucherez ses 340 francs
par an
vous ne toucherez également si vous avez
au moins 3 enfants à charge
même après trois ans mais tout cela
seulement si vos revenus sont inférieurs
à une certaine somme et ce plafond varie
selon les situations
d'abord avec un enfant de moins de 3 ans
et un seul salaire le plafond est à 3600
francs avec un enfant de moins de 3 ans
toujours mais avec deux salaires ce
plafond est à 4300 enfants si vous avez
trois enfants à charge
4400 francs
et toujours avec trois enfants à charge
mais si la famille à deux salaires 5170
francs enfin l'allocation orphelins elle
est augmentée de 50% malgré son nom elle
concerne toutes les familles dites
monoparentales et notamment les mères
célibataires
au total pour répartir 3 milliards 7
le complément familial va toucher plus
de deux millions et demi de famille en
principe à partir du 1er janvier
prochain